[Music]
watching tom through this journey from
the first movie into now has been so
rewarding the first movie is about
spider-man really wanting to prove
himself to tony stark and working so
hard to do that that he ends up screwing
up and making things a million times
worse like that's just exactly how i
felt on the first movie tom and i both
felt the same like where are we what's
going on this is a crazy opportunity
let's not screw it up this is insane
look at this thing look we both grew up
together i don't feel like it was a
parental role i felt like we were all
the kids what's interesting in the
previous films is that he really has
been the spider boy what about me what
about you
i mean what if mrs dark needs me or
something or i don't know something that
goes down and this film is about him
becoming spider-man it's about him
growing up making his own decisions and
stepping up to the plate as a full-blown
avenger and it's been really nice to
kind of have that dovetail between
myself and spider-man homecoming and now
who i am and who peter parker is in
spider-man no way home my name is peter
parker
and i
would like a coffee
please
you